ils sont allés au bout d'eux-mêmes ce
samedi 18 septembre 90 athlètes ont
souffert sur la piste du stade bernard
giroux de plaisir à l'occasion du
meeting d'athlétisme gallia ses plaisirs
l'événement était organisé par le club
local une grande première depuis 1997 ça
commence à faire long conseiller pour
redynamiser un petit peu à cette
histoire il vit noah et locales on
voulait réellement donné hier un nouvel
élan en organisant un meeting en
septembre au programme ce jour là un 200
m 1 400 m 1 1500 m 1 5000 m le planning
a été défini à la dernière minute pour
ce meeting deux reprises déjà appelé
chaque entraîneur pour leur demander
quelles dates horaires où allons-nous
choisir et quelle épreuve alors nous
choisir en fonction du calendrier de
chacun de base ce qu'il a été rajoutée
sur le calendrier initialement prévu et
ils ont choisi en fonction des tas
physique de chacun plusieurs clubs
locaux et normands ont participé à
l'événement franchement la piste unique
ait rien à redire les conditions météo
était parfaite quand ses instincts bon
meeting on est content d'être là parce
que normalement on devait faire un
meeting à cergy pontoise qui a été
annulé donc on est très content de venir
à plaisir d'avoir un fonds de secours ce
que j'allais même pas qu'ils avaient un
ultime si c'est super un nouveau meeting
devrait être organisée cet été par le
club l'objectif sera d'attirer encore
plus de participants avec un programme
plus large
[Applaudissements]